l'arrêt du flassian c'est la recette
qu'ont trouvé les manufacturiers pour
étirer la sauce le prix d'un produit
reste le même mais la quantité est
réduite dans un emballage similaire à
l'ancien format comme ça le consommateur
a moins l'impression de se faire rouler
dans la farine par exemple dans le sac
de chips le cder white costil pour le
fromage on enlève deux tranches par
emballage et sous la bouteille de jus on
amplifie encore un peu le renflement
pour réduire la quantité de liquide
généralement les entreprises s'en
tiennent à des réductions de volume de 5
à 6%
l'expert sylvain charlebois veille au
grain il nous rappelle que nous sommes
plus influencé par une prose de prix que
par une réduction de format la
régulation représente donc un moindre
risque pour les manufacturiers et pour
le consommateur la pilule est plus
facile à avaler au québec
malheureusement pas dans les autres
provinces la loi oblige les détaillants
à préciser les prix par exemple pour 100
g ou 100 millilitres ce qui permet de
comparer des pommes avec des pommes
passer le mot
[Musique]